the artists who played five disparate
characters face their challenges with
skill faith in intelligence for best
performance by an actor in a leading
role the nominees are Robert Downey jr.
in Chaplin hood Eastwood and Unforgiven
Al Pacino in Scent of a Woman
Steven Rae in The Crying Game
Denzel Washington in Malcolm X
and the Oscar the Oscar goes to Al
Pacino in
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you broke my streak
the last guy I was at an affair recently
thank you so much for this I awake him I
was adding a ceremonial type thing like
this recently and I I didn't have a
speech I kept going into my pocket for a
speech but I never wrote them but now I
got one it's here and I should have had
a little water before I'd got on because
my mouth's dry but I thank you and I
just have to say first I don't know
where he is in the house I can't pick
him out but I got to thank him
I'm completely indebted to Marty breast
who who directed the picture and who had
he he had such great love for this
character I played and that love is what
he communicated to me every day
so I thank you Marty for that I thank
beau Goldman who wrote such a
complicated interesting funny guy that
could be and would be any actor's dream
part that part was so great I think I
thank Chris O'Donnell Chris O'Donnell my
co-star and this is he made a every day
a pleasure for me and I thank the
wonderful supportive cast and crew of
course I also want to thank Tom Pollock
and Casey silver at Universal Pictures
and my agent Ric Necedah who urged me to
do this part and actually threatened me
if I didn't do it because I didn't want
to do the part for some reason IRA Lewis
my friend and my colleague who helped me
IRA Lewis and the associated blind for
their generous support to me if you
indulge me for a minute as I just not
used to this so how to write this down I
had this thought and I thought if I ever
got up here I would say it I've been
very lucky
and I I've I've been lucky I found
desire for what I I do early in my life
and I'm lucky because I had people who
encouraged that desire and from Lee
Strasberg to my great friend and mentor
Charlie Lawton to the great writers and
filmmakers that I've been fortunate
enough to work with now recently a young
girl came up to me I was at a function
for the South Bronx which is where I'm
from and she said that I had encouraged
her and that's not necessarily by my
work but just by the fact that we came
from the same place and I just can't
forget that girl and I can't forget the
kids out there who may be thinking
tonight that if he can do it I can do it
so this is really a proud and hopeful
moment for me because I want to thank
the Academy for giving us a gift of
encouragement and this is a gift a great
gift to me I thank you all really
[Applause]
you